Let's now talk about the Trump approval rating
on coronavirus.
Hint it has absolutely imploded.
Now you might remember a few weeks ago.
Now, I guess really like three, three and
a half weeks ago.
Earlier in the Corona virus pandemic, we saw
that Donald Trump was sporting a pretty healthy
approval rating when it came to his handling
of the virus.
And we were wondering why.
And most likely it was a few things that were
sort of bullying for lack of a better term.
Donald Trump's approval rating in general
and on the virus.
Number one, there was this sort of rally around
the president factor, which is often in play
early in a crisis where you have more people
than agree with the president politically,
say, I support the president and they're doing
a good job, at least so far.
You also three and a half weeks ago had a
whole bunch of U.S. states that didn't have
many cases.
So there were many more people in the country
that could feel rightly or wrongly like it
was under control because their state didn't
have many cases.
Now, of course, it is a virus, meaning it
spreads virally.
We now have 13 states with more than 5000
cases.
We have 30 states with more than a thousand
cases and every single state.
Other than Wyoming has had deaths.
So both the reality of rally around the president
and the reality of my state is doing fine.
Both of those things have changed.
They've faded.
And the disapproval now of Trump on the virus
is up 9 points.
It was 43 percent disapproval in mid-March.
It is up to 52 percent disapproval.
That's a climb of more than 20 percent.
And if things keep going the way they're going,
both in terms of the numbers and in terms
of Trump's unhinged response, I would expect
that disapproval on Trump's handling of the
virus is going to keep going up.
The rally around the flag, rally around the
leader stuff is very common, but it doesn't
last forever.
And we have had one of the worst responses
total.
We are testing per capita 30 nine in the world.
Trump regularly claims we are doing the most
tests per capita.
We're not really sure he understands what
per capita means, but he claims that we're
doing the most tests per capita.
Trump insults reporters at press conferences
who ask real questions.
Trump attacks media outlets.
Trump recommends dangerous behavior, suggests
medications during press conferences, brags
about dating models during his press briefings.
And every day we are continuing to see more
and more states have these bigger and bigger
numbers of cases.
Eventually, it was bound to affect his approval.
Now, a few things to keep in mind.
Number one, this kind of piggybacks on our
earlier story about the World Mental Health
Coalition demanding Trump be removed.
Number one, Trump's approval on Corona virus
may keep going down if his handling of the
virus remains poor.
But the power of cults is very strong and
Trump has a powerful cult around him that
is going to support him no matter what.
We're going to get to that a little bit later
with some examples.
But just like Jim Jones got his followers
to drink cyanide laced Kool-Aid.
Trump's followers are going to keep insisting
that Trump is handling this well, just like
Trump says he's doing during his own press
briefings.
So we can.
Only expect his approval to fall a little
bit more because of that cultish support around
him.
Number two, there will be no consequences
to Donald Trump's mishandling of this crisis
unless we remove him in November, which means
voting.
He's not going to be impeached.
He's not going to be removed by the 25th Amendment.
None of it.
So is it good that Trump's approval on Corona
virus is coming down instead of going up?
Yeah, of course it's good.
It means some of the people in this country
are at least tangentially tied to reality.
But Trump's response to the virus has been
diabolical and depraved.
And to see disapproval after two months at
only 52 percent is incredibly disturbing.
And so we just need to be realistic in our
expectations.
Death toll goes up.
They claim the death toll is an accurate.
We started seeing that last week.
Cases spike wildly.
They claim it's only because our testing is
so good and so widespread.
So we've got to remember, they will always
talk their way out of any piece of data that
we can present.
And we can only expect the approval to fall
so much because of the cult of personality
around Donald Trump.
And a little bit later in the show.
I will have some stunning, stunning video
of some of these cultists that you won't believe
or maybe you will believe if you've been watching
the show and paying attention to the news
for the last few years.
Want to remind you, Thursday, this Thursday,
April 9, we are doing a one day membership
bomb.
We lost three hundred and eighty nine members
in March, the most we've ever seen.
Cancel.
And it's because of the tightening of the
belt around the virus.
We understand it.
Everybody is in a.
Many people are in a precarious situation.
So we get it.
So the idea is this Thursday, we're gonna
do a one day membership special biggest discount
of the year.
If you want to be notified by email of the
membership discount code, grab a mailing list
subscription for free at David Pakman dot
com.
Just sign up for our mailing list this Thursday,
2:00 p.m. Eastern, 11:00 a.m.
Pacific.
And email will go out with a code.
And the idea is we've already lost a bunch
of members early in April.
We lost 389 in March.
We want to try to do something cohesive and
community oriented to try to bring back some
of that support.
We're all in this thing together.
Get on that mailing list at David Pakman dot
com.
In the meantime, let me know on Twitter, are
you watching Trump's press briefings on the
virus every day?
Most days, once a week?
Never.
I want to hear from you.
I'm on Twitter at Dipak